Motorcycle drivers zigzag across the
city in Doha
delivering fast food groceries and even
medicine
but when African teams are playing they
can often be found at one of the free
screening sites I'm very proud to be an
African because they came they came and
did a good job which is trending the
name of Africa in this tournament Daniel
brenya came to Qatar from Ghana a little
less than a year ago
catching some World Cup action is a
welcome break from his 12-hour shift in
the work I do I feel very invisible I've
seen Africans performing somewhere in
this tournament and I feel so excited I
feel represented it is motivational
it doesn't matter that their countries
aren't playing at Qatar 2022 Mayu mangas
from The Gambia he says he's followed
the games featuring African sites
closely I'm very much happy and grateful
watching the football here in Qatar and
then I know every African here will be
also happy because we don't know when
are we gonna watch it again
this year was the first time all African
teams won at least one match in the
group stage sub-Saharan Africans make up
roughly six percent of the population in
Qatar football is by far the most
popular sport back home and for many of
these migrant workers being this close
to a FIFA World Cup is a once in a
lifetime experience
Gerard aquindes is a former professional
athlete and Coach these days he's a
professor at Northwestern University
working in sports management in Africa
Africans here large majority Blue Collar
jobs or service low service jobs for
them Qatar who presents something
exceptional
and moreover African teams doing well
and that is very exceptional and is a
moment of Pride for all those people who
are normally not socially at a high
level either in their society or here
then Qatar represents an opportunity a
representative stage that give them
value yeah yes the 90 minutes passes all
too quickly and it's time to get back on
the road again to customers they may be
faceless nameless service providers but
behind the uniforms and helmets are
passionate supporters of African
football
in Al Jazeera